je dois vous demander quelque chose
je ne sais pas à quel point
oui,
alors combien de temps diriez-vous que vous avez
des symptômes
comme un mois
je peux me souvenir de certaines choses mais d'autres
choses sont juste parties comme euh des détails je
ne peux pas faire de détails
ils  appelez ça une
affection neuro-inflammatoire et cela peut
affecter n'importe qui
comme l'homme ramassé par un arc de pêche,
il s'est avéré qu'il était un autre pêcheur
ne se rappelant pas comment diriger sa ceinture,
alors il a décidé de rentrer chez lui à la nage
, puis un pilote a oublié comment voler
si  vous présentez des
symptômes j'ai besoin de vous ici
le gouvernement a le vrai remède
qu'ils ont gardé nia dans la rue
il n'y a personne pour devenir fou
ce n'est pas un remède éprouvé nous exhortons
tout le monde à rester calme
donc le traitement est-il comme un  pilule ou
nous allons faire une ponction crânienne orale
désolé ce que le cerveau est séparé en
quatre lobes principaux pense que c'est comme dégager
une voie obstruée
qui ai-je
quel âge ai-je
quelle est ma couleur préférée
tu es ma femme
emma vida ryerson williams
toi  es 2  8
ta couleur préférée est le
jaune
oh moi tremble en moi
[Musique]
je me souviens d'un parc aquatique
quelle période de l'année était-ce l'
été
pas l'
hiver
où tu venais d'acheter un poisson
quand il a commencé à perdre la mémoire
elle l'avait gardé secret
juste  comme tout le monde l'a fait batman
[Musique]
tous ces petits morceaux
je me demande comment construire un
avenir si tu dois continuer à reconstruire le
passé
ils disent que tu ne peux pas oublier les sentiments
et je crois toujours que
c'est quoi c'est un poisson ouais j'ai attrapé
avec toi
pourquoi tatoues-tu frais ouais tu vas
bien
[Musique]
toi